ce sera à matignon réunion du
gouvernement le matin découverte
alimente madame monsieur bonsoir le
mouvement des chômeurs domine à nouveau
l'actualité politique aujourd'hui en
france avec une journée très chargée
pour lionel jospin à matignon qui a reçu
tour à tour les organisations syndicales
et qui reçoit ce soir l'ensemble des
associations engagées dans le mouvement
faisons d'abord le point sur ces
entrevues avec laurent bailly les
régissent mettait devant les caméras et
sous les flashes
les sourires sont de rigueur mais le
premier ministre a voulu donner un ton
solennel aux rencontres de cet après
midi tour à tour les leaders des grands
sa fille
et des représentants du patronat se sont
succédé dans son bureau au menu des
discussions la lutte contre le chômage
et des moyens de mettre en oeuvre pour
apaiser l'actuel mouvement des sans
emploi les chômeurs que matignon aux
seynois aussi dans l'heure qui vient
c'est une première et ça fait bondir
marc blondel je veux simplement essayé
de mettre en garde tous ceux qui
pourrait un jour avoir comme espérance
d'opposer ceux qui n'ont pas de travail
à ceux qui ont du travail
en tout cas il n'y aura pas ce soir au
chômage de réponse spectaculaire mais
lionel jospin va annoncer demain
plusieurs décisions dans la mesure de
ses moyens
le premier ministre a simplement
beaucoup insisté pour que les mesures
qu'il allait annoncer reste compatible
et dans le cadre des orientations de la
politique économique et monétaire qui
est celle de ce gouvernement
peut-être est-ce un plus la quadrature
du cercle d'ailleurs ce que nous lui
recommandons c'est que le financement de
ces dispositions se fasse par
redéploiement de crédits n'ont pas
d'autres mesures d'économies afin que le
coup tu ne pèse pas d'une manière
exagérée sur la croissance et l'emploi
et tous les syndicats déplorent que la
marge de manoeuvre soit aussi limité la
cgt elle en rend responsable les
employeurs compte tenu de l'énorme
responsabilité que porte le patronat
dans cette situation là si j'étais bien
décidé à continuer cette initiative
d'action car les problèmes restent
toujours
même si le premier ministre faisait un
geste demain sur les minimums sociaux
laffrey retraite
cela ne suffira peut-être pas à apaiser
les associations de chômeurs qui pour la
première fois ce soir elle roule le
ballon je vous lisez ces réunions se
poursuivent ce soir ce n'est que demain
que je ferai connaître les mesures
envisagées par le gouvernement
quelle peut être sa marge de manoeuvre
autrement dit quelle est la
responsabilité de l'unedic celle de
l'état quels sont les différents statuts
et les différentes prestations dont
bénéficient les travailleurs privés
d'emploi
jean-paul chapelle l'inédit qu indemnise
aujourd'hui un million sept cent
cinquante cinq mille chômeurs soit à peu
près la moitié des demandeurs d'emploi
celui qui perd son emploi perçoit dans
un premier temps location à temps plein
en moyenne 57 force en dépréciant la
durée de cotisation ensuite le chômeurs
touchent une allocation unique
dégressive elle diminue de 10 7%
tous les six mois au bout le chômeur se
retrouvent en fin de droit il n'est plus
prise en charge par l'unedic mais par
l'état qui finance les minima sociaux
notamment l'allocation de solidarité
spéciale de 1300 kg par mois en moyenne
près des 500 du chemin la russie
pour y avoir droit cinq ans les autres
une insertion suis pas un million
d'allocataires de minima sociaux
sur le terrain les occupations se
poursuivent occupation et l'évacuation
au fil des heures
comme ce fut le cas cet après midi aux
assedic de lille ou à celle du val de
marne évacués par les forces de l'ordre
à marseille une délégation de chômeurs a
été reçue au siège patronales mais
bouches du rhône une trentaine de
manifestants entendaient réclamer une
contribution du patronat qui détient la
moitié des sièges et poncet les
illustrations les mini leulier lic
ailleurs comme dans les locaux de la
dass à paris à la trésorerie générale de
besançon ou encore à la mairie de lyon
les comités de chômeurs multiplient les
opérations de points olivier caro cnj
qu'elles ont suivi le comité d'asnières
qui navigue depuis trois jours entre
l'occupation des caisses des assedic et
c'est les locaux de l'anpe entre les
forces de l'ordre et les chômeurs
mécontents des hauts-de-seine
c'est presque le jeu du chat et de la
souris et ça fait quatre jours que ça
dure depuis lundi ils sont une trentaine
leur première action
l'occupation de sept antennes assedic du
monde et combien il me disait de
chômeurs des militants de quatre
associations différentes îles deux
meneurs ancien vététiste à l'humanité
sans emploi depuis cinq ans muriel
milite activement dans la section
chômeurs de la cgt depuis les grèves de
95 à fait partie des fondateurs d'agir
contre le chômage
une association qui l'a quittée depuis
et oui blanche et quelques litres de
café plus tard c'est toujours lui qui
préparent la manifestation de l'après
midi devant le siège de l'unedic
tous les mouvements nationaux qui se
sont occupés du chômage sont présentés
dans cet espace de façon en fin d'année
il ya une entente entre nous au bout de
deux jours comprend à demi mots ont ré
partager les tâches sans avoir à faire
des tractations
on met cinq minutes à rédiger des tracts
commun en attendant la libération des
lieux d'un direction des assedic a fait
fermer les guichets pour muriel pas
question de laisser les autres chômeurs
dehors elle prend la place des
fonctionnaires
la popularité du bourg dès qu une
entreprise et niveau le prouver aux
autorités du département le plus riche
de france qui aurait peut-être qu'après
la manifestation
il nous fait un petit répit et une
grande lassitude
ce matin quelque part dans la ville
robert décroche à nouveau son téléphone
donc on a réoccupé en fait un à changer
de lieu
on est allé les jeunes vignes et je sais
pas si cela rappelle la directrice de
l'anpe est débordé
les élus locaux ont précédé leur dignité
le maire a mis la pression
s'il ya des échéances électorales
j'en profite on en profite mais en
attendant d'en profiter c'est l'état de
siège à une période où les chômeurs des
hauts-de-seine ont décidé de passer la
nuit et la question des chômeurs étaient
bien sûr au centre de la réunion de ce
matin à matignon le nez jospin il
réunissait l'ensemble de son
gouvernement
avec un mot d'ordre collégialité et
solidarité au sein de l'équipe en soit
david et jacques leblanc et les ligues
la victime à l'hôtel matignon un jeudi
sur deux c'est le défilé des voitures
ministérielles séminaire gouvernemental
au bik donc plus à petit que d'autres
avant de recevoir syndicat patronal
chômeurs pourrait bloquer le mouvement
des sans emploi avait besoin de mettre
un peu d'ordre
on savait pas
dominique voynet tu marie george buffet
elle en est à déguster de martine aubry
en prenant publiquement fait et cause
pour les chômeurs
aujourd'hui la ministre communiste
félicitait du dialogue intra
gouvernementale qui est tout simplement
curiel et cohérent ce matin mercredi bas
pourtant le prix n'a pas mâché ses mots
en rappelant son équipe la nécessité
d'un fonctionnement collégial et
solidaire du gouvernement
ceci posé il était temps de débattre de
la résolution du conflit tout le
gouvernement que ce soit maintenant la
profondeur de la quiétude et sans emploi
sans tarder répondre depuis cet après
midi le premier ministre en première
ligne et tout le gouvernement est
derrière lui et sa basse matignon où les
entreprises poursuit avec les comités de
chômeurs nous allons trouver jean michel
a raconté jean michel bonsoir lui à dos
fin est monté en première ligne
aujourd'hui un exercice délicat et
presque tardif pour réaffirmer sa
méthode de gouvernement
il sait rencontre décidée à toute
vitesse comme un grenelle de l' urgence
la première fois une hésitation dans les
méthodes jospin certains syndicalistes
parlent même de défaillance il ya trois
semaines tout le monde
nicole notât jean pierre chevènement et
martine aubry étaient d'accord pour
faire évacuer les quelques assedic
occupés soient complétées opposé le
premier ministre en raison de la forte
symbolique du chômage
le conflit est donc duré jusqu'à la
journée d'action d'hier ou tel modèle
mais devant le risque d'enlisement
lionel jospin est obligé de reprendre
les choses en main il réprimande les
ministres qui ont soutenu le mouvement
il demande à martine aubry de radoub sur
les propos qu'elle a tenus ce qu'elle
n'a pas forcément apprécié d'ailleurs
enfin il devrait annoncer des mesures
qu'il espère que convaincante pour les
chômeurs et pour les français
cet après midi n'a rien dit de ses
intentions à ses interlocuteurs leurs
affluents néanmoins les difficultés
économiques du moment
sous-entendu il ne peut pas y avoir de
miracle on saura demain si cette méthode
est la bonne et pour l'instant dans la
cour de matignon arrivent les comités
les associations de chiens qui sont
juste à côté de moi merci je me sert
effectivement les vois arriver sous les
yeux de des caméras et de la presse
de son côté plus tôt ce matin jacques
chirac pour sauver les voeux de ce que
l'on appelle les forces vives du pays
autrement dit les représentants du monde
patronal syndical associatif il y en a
profité pour mettre en garde le
gouvernement contre le poids excessif du
secteur public dans l'économie
nous écoutons jacques chirac de tous les
pays occidentaux nos concurrents dans un
monde ouvert
nous sommes celui où les créations
d'emplois dans le secteur privé ont été
les moins nombreuses au cours des
dernières années et où l'emprunt public
a le plus progressé
un jour ou l'autre vient l'épreuve de
vérité
comment financer à un niveau si élevé
le fonctionnement de l'état et des
collectivités publiques sans freiner le
développement de l'activité et de
l'emploi par des prélèvements accessible
ce question n'est ni de gauche ni de
droite
elle est d'intérêt national et notre
pays ne peut pas lutter mais pour être
complet sur ce dossier politique ne des
emprunts à cette prise de position de
jean louis debré le président du groupe
rpr l'assemblée qui trouve légitime le
mouvement les fumeurs face à ce qu'il
appelle la capacité du gouvernement à
mieux les problèmes de la france
les habitants de la région de saint-omer
capelle n'ont pas calé en est pour le
moins une nuit agitée une mini tornade
s'est abattue sur plusieurs communes
détruisant tout sur son passage
heureusement il n'y a que cinq blessés
mais 230 maisons ont été endommagées et
certaines complètement métriques le
reportage de places d'amour gay 2
patrick berche pas
la tornade n'a duré que quelques
secondes et les dégâts sont
considérables
les rafales de vents de 250 km je veux
traiter dormait au premier étage sa
maison utilise lui toute la journée il a
nettoyé et des gravats mais il a
finalement dû se résoudre à partie c'est
mon péché alors une maille bas d'après
le mail en jeu le maire et je mets la
main une quarantaine de familles on
parle si été relogées ou hébergés par
des proches
impuissants les habitants ne peuvent que
constater les dégâts
l'église du village décapiter le pylône
électrique à terre le garagiste n'a pas
eu plus de chance
son atelier est dévasté à minuit et demi
le temps s'est comme arrêté je siffle et
s'étale à lyon un gros boum on a déjà
les régions il est tombé sur le gard la
tornade surpris les habitants en plein
sommeil le souffle est si violent qu'il
encore vu les toitures de la moitié du
village
bien mieux sur l'autoroute balaie tout
sur son passage en quelques lignes
aquaria une toiture plus de portes
fenêtres de mails ou des quartiers en
fait ça s'est passé les 30 secondes
moi j'ai vu des choses du drone dans la
maison qui a profité tout blanc las de
voir une bombe toute la journée jeux
chez sur les toits pompiers habitants
secouristes tentent de reconstruire
relate une toiture rétablir
l'électricité
effacer les traces de la catastrophe on
a encore eu à dormir il est possible de
déterminer avec précision le montant des
dégâts est ce coup de vent ne venait pas
de plaque les catastrophes naturelles
ce type de tornades de rentrer en effet
pas dans cette catégorie et c'est donc
maintenant voir leur assureur que les
personnes souhaiteraient vont devoir se
tourner pour espérer obtenir une
indemnisation
il souhaite aux tornades ont su
traverser la manche pour dévaster la
ville de sel c'est au sud-est de
l'angleterre
les vents tourbillonnants là aussi on
atteint 1 160 km est remportant les
toits des maisons faisant exploser les
fenêtres et entraînant l'évacuation de
centaines d'habitants
ce genre de tornades est un phénomène
assez rare en france surtout en cette
saison il serait due notamment à la
stabilité de l'air actuellement et à la
température de la mer qui est très
supérieur à la normale les explications
de josé dans la pierre et le bois
chauffe l'eau de mer a tiré par le ciel
et la tornade et demi par un amateur ou
de l'angleterre
à l'origine un énorme nuage d'orage
formé au dessus de la mer
alimenté par une
chaude une gigantesque chaudière quant
au ciel en temps bio n'en concède tabac
sur la côte
nathan lane meurt mais sur quelques
kilomètres sont partagés dévastateur la
thrombose que forme la nuit dernière à
22 heures au large de brighton à minuit
elle touche les côtes françaises mais sa
puissante échappe aux prévisions les
radars montrait bien des
des pluies donc des averses mais cela ne
nous dit pas tout cette averse les vents
sont tourbillonnant et donc provoquer
tornade
donc en fait on constate le phénomène on
a énormément de mal à le prévoir la
responsable c'est la douceur installé
sur l'europe depuis noël - dick à paris
l'année dernière à cette époque plus
vite cette année une anomalie climatique
qui se répercute sur la mer et la
réchauffe de façon exceptionnelle + 2
degrés par rapport à la normale
largement suffisant pour provoquer le
phénomène de la trombe d'eau a
mécaniquement con energy
donc il nous plutôt chambre
celui d'environ deux corps match à
gagner l'une des plus violentes date de
1960 à l'époque la vase et de la peine
avait été ravagé
il y a deux ans disparaissait françois
mitterrand jacques chirac a fait déposer
une vert ce matin sous sa tente à jarnac
lionel jospin fait de même et françois
hollande pour le ps a souligné ce que
collectivement les socialistes nuit
dorée dans la maîtrise vingtaine de
membres de la famille de françois
mitterrand bon sa veuve daniel son fils
jean christophe et sa fille mazarine se
sont également recueillis sur la tombe
de l'ancien chef de l'état
mais deux ans après sa disparition à
jarnac où il est enterré le souvenir de
l'ancien président la république s'est
quelque peu estompée il ya moins curieux
moins de touristes en soi privat et bien
damien la charente que françois
mitterrand aimait considéré comme un
fleuve jarnac célèbre lançant du pays
avec discrétion dans le plus pur esprit
charente est désormais la ville natale
de l'ancien président de la république
vit dans le souvenir tranquille
lance sa place et avec le temps les
touristes ont déserté les allées du
cimetière des grand'maisons quelques
souvenirs du plus mauvais goût ont pu
choquer mais aujourd'hui ce magasin est
définitivement fermée jarnac n'est pas
le colombes et du socialisme en
l'annoncé dès le départ on ne voulait
pas se pendre
ça n'est pas aux normes au niveau
fréquentation est ce que ces récits
sensiblement on a eu une première année
assez exceptionnel je suis retraité même
des fichiers mois supportable par
certains moments et à abéché 50% ce qui
me semble tout à fait dans l'ordre des
choses sur la sépulture de françois
mitterrand
aucun signe distinctif seulement
quelques roses pour le symbole on prend
prolé venir on n'était jamais venu
aujourd'hui on avait décidé combien
droite aujourd'hui beaucoup plus intime
détenir aujourd'hui de plaques
commémoratives non plus sur la façade de
la maison natale de françois mitterrand
un must au détour d'une rue est l'un des
quais de la ville portent également le
nom de l'ancien président je pense qu'il
est bon que la mémoire reste mais il est
passé il n'y a qu'une personnalité et
pour marquer le deuxième anniversaire de
la mort de françois mitterrand
l'exposition sur les grands travaux a
été offerte à la ville de jarnac
elle vient d'être installé dans un
ancien chai à cognac
à quelques mètres de la charente quel
est le rôle du lycée comment doit-on y
enseigner c'est l'objet du questionnaire
distribué à partir d'aujourd'hui à tous
les lycéens et leur enseignant france
une vaste consultation à l'initiative de
claude allègre qui se terminera par un
colloque en avril prochain en vue de la
grande réforme des lycées
nathalie moisan et jean libon serre
mais trop compliqué et comme tu sais
oise des questions mois pour les adultes
que la revue questions les réponses sont
les premiers à découvrir le
questionnaire envoyé par l'éducation
nationale à chacun d'entre eux mêmes
s'ils apprécient d'être consulté leur
jugement est critique
elle n'est pas de plus sur l'école ne
changera pas leur avenir
on remarque plus trop ça on n'a que le
petit problème c'est que la grippe on
peut faire battre +2 à bac +5 ou peut
avoir des diplômes avec une vous n'êtes
pas forcément pour moi transactions
professionnelles
j'écris je crois pas parce que je vois
que ma porte pour mon insertion
professionnelle carte yvon paré inutile
et que vous apprenez aux idées qui vous
ennuie les questions qui portent
essentiellement sur les programmes
l'objectif c'est les élèves à la raison
de délais voulus par le ministre je
pense que si on appliquait davantage les
jeunes dans les décisions qui les
concernent il y aurait moins de geste de
révolte les jeunes que si les
professeurs et pourtant cet
établissement trois questionnaires
différents vont être distribués en tout
près de 4 millions d'exemplaires
les syndicats d'enseignants pourtant que
des garanties soient données pour le
dépouillement de cette consultation et
nous espérons bien que ce ne sera pas
une consultation alibi pour les options
déjà prises et nos mises sur la table
pour les enseignants comme pour les
lycéens les réticences pour que sur
l'avenir du questionnaire tous ses
repères qu'il ne restera pas
ensuite les bons résultats de la sncf et
pertes cette année ont été inférieures à
un milliard de francs c'est ce qu'a
indiqué louis gallois le président de
l'entreprise en s'en félicitant tous les
trafics de les cff sont en progression
marchandises et passagers il faut dire
aussi que la réforme de la sncf qui pour
beaucoup avec un désendettement massif
de 134 milliards votée par le parlement
en février dernier et un coup de pouce
supplémentaire de l'état de 28 milliards
ces derniers jours une centaine
d'agriculteurs de la confédération
paysanne s'en sont pris à des sacs de
maïs transgénique scène s'est déroulée à
nérac lot-et-garonne
une dizaine de ces sacs suspects ont été
éventrées par ces agriculteurs en colère
qui protestent contre l'arrivée de ce
maïs en france importé qui le sont par
une société suisse
les échauffourées avec les forces de
l'ordre un colloque sur les aides sur le
net sous les halles vergy pardon c'était
actuellement à paris nous fait découvrir
un certain nombre de causes nouvelle on
connaissait les tristement célèbres
acariens qui se déroule qui se développe
dans le matelas et oreillers
on apprend aujourd'hui qu'une
alimentation trop varié des enfants dès
leur très jeune âge peut être cause
d'allergie france fasse valette et
bernard au fleix dans la calle martineau
tout le monde est allergique
un peu d'eczéma un peu d'asthme mais
rien de très grave sauf pour victor à
quatre mois il a eu un écho mac rêver de
graves problèmes de peau qui ont duré
plus de deux ans aujourd'hui il a encore
quelques poussées d'eczéma plus c'est
pas rentable
le cas tous les laits toutes les viandes
tous les légumes le blé les yeux la
chine en résumé en fait victor s'est
nourri pendant deux ans 2 le poulet
uniquement poulet est un petit peu de
colère de riverains pas me taire mais
sort n'a pas suivi de traitement et de
cortisone les régimes alimentaires frais
ont mécaniquement amélioré car très
souvent chez l'enfant en dessous de 12
ans l'eczéma que l'on appelle aussi
dermatite atopique est liée à
l'alimentation
il est démontré dans certaines études en
particulier que une diversification
précoce avec un certain nombre
d'aliments lorsqu'il ya des antécédents
familiaux d'énergie favorisent la
survenue d'une arme atomique et que dans
ces conditions on peut faire une
certaine prévention en retard dans la
diversification alimentaire ayant dès
lors à l'enfant - aliments que leur
diversité sur l'homme
malheureusement on ne pense pas à
l'allergie alimentaire généralement
plusieurs aliments compte en cause des
tests permettent de les identifier
je crois qu'un enfant qui n dermatite
atopique doit être vu rapidement pour
empêcher que sept enfants contractent un
l'asthme de trois ans il est donc
important d'intervenir le plus tôt
possible pour éviter les allergies
des chercheurs français ont découvert un
point clé non pas du plaisir mais de la
dépendance à la nicotine le point
question se trouverait dans le cerveau
et sa découverte pourrait déboucher
éventuellement sur de nouvelles méthodes
de sevrage les fumeurs mais le plus
intéressant est ailleurs nous dit jean
daniel flaysakier certains mais river de
la nicotine pourrait servir à lutter
contre des maladies comme la maladie
c'est une série très spéciale et coûte
très cher obtenir la bonne nouvelle ce
qui ne coûte rien aux cigarettes en
effet génétiquement elle ne peut
présenter aucune dépendance à la
nicotine
c'est grave d'en savoir atteindre de
l'institut pasteur on vient de découvrir
l'endroit du sial où se trouve le
secteur qui provoque justement la
dépendance à la nicotine la nicotine
qu'une substance qui avait fait n'est
pas bien connue notamment sur le coeur
sur les vaisseaux et l'entraînent chez
certains fumeurs une dépendance
responsable d'une vraie petit commeinhes
et cette toxicomanie
on sait maintenant l'expliqué la
nicotine bien sûr certaines familles
nerveux elle provoque la libération
d'une substance à dopamine en grande
quantité et cela entraîne des
perturbations dans le cerveau connaître
cela secteur de la dépendance est très
important car les dérivés de nicotine
font l'objet de grandes altéré dans la
recherche de nouveaux traitements
notamment dans la douleur il sait aussi
dans d'autres affections chroniques
comme la maladie de parkinson maladie
d'alzheimer pour certaines maladies
psychiatriques
il fonce la loire ont su réagir ses
produits les molécules qui ne ne
produiront pas dépendance mais clipon
qui éviteront soigneusement les
récepteurs que nous avons sur lesquels
nous allons travailler mais qui est
seront actifs dans les autres régions du
cerveau qui ils sont responsables
analgésie mais évite la douleur le
premier dérivé de la nicotine utilisé en
traitement des douleurs est
expérimentalement 100 fois plus efficace
que la morphine études animales ont
montré l'absence d'effets secondaires
l'aspiration à l'absence de constipation
ils ont surtout montré qu'il n'y avait
pas de dépendance est dérivé de la
nicotine sont sans doute très utile
la nicotine et la cigarette contient la
pénurie n'est pas c'est déjà bien connu
les propos de jean marie le pen à munich
sur les chambres à gaz détail de
l'histoire selon lui et bien cette
reprise ne lui valent pas seulement des
poursuites en allemagne il est mis en
examen en france par le juge parisien
jean paul va là pour contestation de
crimes contre l'humanité sous le même
chef d'accusation le procès de roger
garaudy fait ouvert aujourd'hui devant
la 17e chambre correctionnelle à paris
roger garaudy est poursuivi pour que ces
propos dans son livre intitulé les
mythes fondateurs de la politique
israélienne lors de la sortie de ce
livre il avait reçu l'appui controversée
de son vieil ami l'abbé pierre florange
nokia les clichés j'ai garaudy 84 ans
ancien professeur d'université
on sera député sénateur communiste
converti à l'islam au corps de 53 l'île
dont celui qui la mène aujourd'hui en
correctionnelle
elle est accusée de compression de
crimes contre l'humanité pour avoir
parlé du mickey et minnie les juifs
exterminés
pour les avocats de la partie civile
c'est le présente la licra le mrap et
les appréciations des déportés gk mode
est un écrivain c'est pire c'est un
négationniste le mot les sionistes ne
rien dire
tous les historiens sont révisionniste à
monsieur l'arrondi est strictement
faussaires la défense pour l'instant
d'entrer dans ce débat est prête à
refuser toute la liberté d'expression
depuis la loi gayssot de 1990
cette loi ne vise pas ce qu'ils
contesteraient le massacre ou d août le
massacre des somaliens le massacre des
palestiniens
tous les matins les massacres des
arméniens tous les génocides qui sont
susceptibles d'être discuté on a le
droit de dire ce sont des détails une
réalité globalement bonetti jugement de
dieu révèle une religion que je rate et
le sionisme
une politique que je combats à mains
nues roger garaudy à la barre et à
l'appel de l'abbé pierre lettre écrite
en novembre 1990 dans laquelle le
fondateur d'emmaüs lui renouvelle une
fois de plus confiance
un suicide collectif façon nous été
évitée en espagne de la police de santa
cruz de tenerife dans l'archipel des
canaries a arrêté une trentaine de
membres d'une secte en majorité des
britanniques et des allemands qui se
préparait au suicide pour rejoindre son
coup de volant qui devait passer par un
on ne sait pas pour l'instant si cette
secte est une ramification de l'ordre du
temple solaire
les responsables des polices de huit
pays européens se sont réunis à rome
pour examiner la question kurde plus de
200 immigrés clandestins originaires du
kurdistan sont déjà arrivés en italie
depuis le début de l'année il s'agissait
pour ces responsables de la police
d'examiner les mesures à prendre pour y
faire face sur place que portal philippe
rochot lesjak gerin les patrons de la
police de sept pays européens et de la
turquie ont d'abord réussi à calmer la
polémique diriger
lisez de laxisme et de laisser passer
les clandestins vers d'autres pays
d'europe
le directeur de la police nationale
française qui participaient à cette
réunion confirme que la turquie
acceptent de freiner l'exode à la source
mais des mesures sont prises pour
démanteler les filières clandestines
les interpellations que nous avons faits
très salma conjointement en france en
italie nous ont montré qu'il y avait des
filières organisées qui du reste se
confondent avec des filières de la
criminelle organismes et nous avons
décidé par conséquent me mettre l'accent
sur le démantèlement de ces filières
pour une raison simple c'est que si
cette filière d'immigration n'existe pas
les flux sont bien évidemment très
réduit le mouvement de sympathie pour
les kurdes est assez fort en italie
beaucoup plus que pour les alba l'air et
c'est ce qui inquiète quelque peu les
chefs de la police qui s'attendent à
voir les italiens leur accorder
peut-être un peu trop facilement l'asile
politique est arrivé en italie nombre de
ces cures de tente de rejoindre
l'allemagne où ils ont souvent de la
famille c'est pour que les autorités
allemandes ont renforcé les contrôles
notamment sur le pont de l'europe entre
strasbourg et kehl richard pinet et rémy
poissonnier le bus va taire toutes les
20 minutes
kra la cellera pour relier strasbourg à
l allemand
mais sur le pont de l'europe la police
indienne et rabat effective control est
le fruit de kurdes chaque jour temps de
rejoindre l'allemagne
un peu à l'écart des policiers veillent
et contrôle tous les accès à bretton
woods et semaine passée nous avons à 84
ans réfugié par jour et il est exclu à
la police des frontières
les fonctionnaires l'express que dès
qu'un candidat mais laxisme le sol
allemand
il peut alerter de moins donc aux
réunions nous a légué par le pr non
seulement leur identité est seulement de
la ville
nous les aurions tourner vers les
services concernés outre les frontières
par brook à 60 km de mer c'est l'église
protestante 45 kurdes de turquie ont
entamé une grève de l'art demandeur
d'asile depuis deux trois voire cinq ans
ils ont épuisé tout court et ont reçu
leur avis d'expulsion mon village été
détruits subissons verte et ont pris le
matin les autres sont partis il y aurait
à madiana
depuis l'entrée de l'italie dans
l'accord de schengen
deux demandes de doubler côté de
français 250 réfugiés kurdes ont été
interpellés c'est fort calibre alors que
le journal algérien le soir fait à
nouveau état 2000 sacre dans l'ouest du
pays une trentaine de personnes il
aurait été assassiné
alger acceptent de recevoir une mission
de la troïka européenne c'est-à-dire des
représentants du luxembourg de la
grande-bretagne et de l'autriche
c'est ce qui a été annoncé à londres
tony blair referais jacques santer le
président de la commission européenne
il semblerait également que le
gouvernement algérien qui refusait
jusqu'à présent toute ingérence dans ses
affaires intérieures
accepte la venue d'une mission de l'onu
après ce journal un des reportages
d'envoyé spécial sera consacré à cette
question de l'algérie les états unis
accueille avec prudence les propos du
président iranien à cnn
mohammad khatami qui a fait une offre de
dialogue au peuple américain
mais pour washington dont les relations
sont toujours rompues avec l'iran le
dialogue ne peut se faire que d'état rip
jean marc loos le cuir noir descendant
très aimé du prophète ce n'est pas
d'investir ni de grand satan américain
hier soir sur cnn ou à mettre au tamis
le nouveau président modéré de la
république islamique d'iran en anglais
remet en appeler au dialogue
sinon avec le gouvernement des états
unis mais moins avec je cite la grande
civilisation américaine
à l'origine de la rupture entre
washington et téhéran de la 17 ans déjà
l'humiliante prise d'otage des
diplomates américains deuxième surprise
les frotte à me présenter regrets à la
grande colère du récent plan des
religieux
washington des juges aujourd'hui ces
déclarations encourageantes d'être sans
encaisser sa garde un dialogue il
pourtant les terrorismes armes de
destruction massive entre israël et les
palestiniens
élu triomphalement la surprise générale
en mai dernier par une majorité de
jeunes et de femmes costil au
conservatisme religieux faute a mis le
mot la réforme il est donc entrouvert la
porte vers une normalisation iran etats
unis n est pas encore au coin de la rue
c'est l'adversaire est aussi puissant
comme green town au parlement de téhéran
le dégel a commencé le sport maintenant
et la sévérité de la fédération
française de football contre les joueurs
convaincus de dopage trois footballeurs
français dont vincent guérin du paris
saint germain sont condamnés à 12 mois
de suspension dont six mois ferme
il avait été contrôlé positif à la
nandrolone un anabolisant
une sanction qui ne comprennent pas dans
la mesure où l'acte eu de la fédération
n'a pas toujours été la même yanam
lorsque la colère est trop forte
certains comme antoine s'il ya ce qui se
replient sur eux-mêmes en silence
alors que d'autres contrats tard je
renvoie là un petit peu la balle ils ont
une fédération de judo qu'il ait
secrètement à bois spray défendent une
fédération de 6 500 aux etats-unis
je crois qu'il ya pas trop de cohérence
donc il faut un peu raide amir les
valeurs à savoir qui c'est qui décide un
petit peur parce qu'il vaut
les trois joueurs lourdement sanctionnés
aujourd'hui ne comprennent pas le volte
face de la commission présidée par le
docteur au bureau elle avait décidé il
ya un mois de surseoir à statuer sur le
cas de cyril pouget et admis des doutes
scientifiques à propos des cas positifs
à la nandrolone doute en tout cas
acceptable sur une pénalité production
de l'humain et 1,12 à mois plus tard le
docteur audureau n'a apparemment plus de
doute
les trois joueurs pensent qu'il a subi
de fortes pressions venant du ministère
de la jeunesse et des sports et que leur
sort était scellé d'avancé et aucune
chance à décision n'était pas un gros
minet 3 les dés étaient pipés d'avancé
et donc à partir de là je crois que pour
eux ils ont des certitudes de nantes
vannes
malgré tous les arguments scientifiques
on a pu développer cet après-midi et
toutes les questions qui n'ont pas été
levés pour en est capable à 100% et vous
renseigne à ce qui est dommage comme si
bien ce qui est arrivé à jay vincent
guérin va faire appel et se battre
contre cette sanction qui risque de
marquer la fin de sa carrière
en football un démenti de l'om marseille
a priori très vite fabrizio ravanelli
resterait à l'om il ne passerait pas à
milan c'est ce qu'affirme rolland
courbis l'entraîneur marseillais
toujours à propos de lepage cette
surprise des autorités australiennes à
l'arrivée des nageuses chinoise pour les
championnats du monde de natation dans
les bagages de la spécialiste de la
brasse ils ont découvert des hormones de
croissance france au grade la gauche la
délégation à la nation dimanche
généreux à ma droite la presse
australienne enfin faudrait remonter à
force de chercher depuis une semaine ils
ont fini par se trouvait ce matin à
l'aéroport de sydney motif les douanes
viennent de découvrir dans les médias
sur une nageuse trèfle a consulté sur
chaque flacon une étiquette sur chaque
étiquette un nom somato trop fine une
hormone de passants cette visée pour
traiter les personnes qui ont un
problème de croissance morizet aussi la
croissance corporels en du canon a
peut-être compris en remplacement de
stéroïdes anabolisants
d'après les nombres de l'équipe chinoise
dans ces femmes ont ignoré que du sud de
tours d'ailleurs on peut se demander
pourquoi marc et lisiblement le nom d'un
produit interdit sur un flacon produits
qui d'après l'ancien champion américain
mark fried doit être pris bien avant la
période de compétition pour faire son
effet elle produit peut nous seront
analysés que demain mais la presse
australienne l1 déjà condamné douch loi
depuis plusieurs jours il faut dire qu
aux derniers championnats du monde à
rome
94 lits chinoise
lombez puis assigné en levant 19
médailles douze mois plus tard prête
d'entre eux
l'entraîneur australien a d'ores et déjà
demandé à tous la tête de tourner le dos
aux chinois he s'il se trouvait sur un
même podium mondial quatre semaines et
leur tournée franchement traîne pas de
répit n'était troqué les mésaventures
olympique qui a commencé sa tournée à
travers le japon pour les jeux
olympiques d'hiver à nagano
compte tenu des conditions météo vous
voyez s est éteinte à quatre reprises
heureusement une flamme témoin en
quelque sorte suivaient jusque derrière
on avons pu la ranimer
à chaque fois les principaux titres de
ce journal avec d'abord la journée
comment lé comité
une mini tornade s'abat en plein marais
les prévisions météo de ce fait à fond
20h50 et magazines de la relation
spéciale avec nous et demain à 20 heures
vous progressez même béatrice jamais
cela
numéro de carte